(applause and cheering)
- She's so excited.
(excited laughter)
- Sit down.
I know you're excited.
- I love you so much.
- [Josh Gad] Oh my god,
I love you so much.
- And I was telling you, she loves you.
- Your voice, so iconic.
- These are real tears.
You are the, oh no.
- She loves you.
I'm telling you.
- Oh my God.
- [Kelly] No, but here.
Can I, can I tell you my favorite part?
Cause I was reading her pre-interview,
and all the things,
like I've seen you in "Book of Mormon,"
I've seen you in "Frozen,"
or heard you in "Frozen,"
all these things you've done.
Tell him what, the one you mentioned?
- Bear Claw.
- Bear Claw or New Girl, that's her poll.
- I also loved Wedding Ringer.
- Oh, thank you.
You're too young to see that but okay.
(excited laughter)
(clapping and laughter)
- You are so unbelievably talented.
- Thank you.
- We were listening to your
song in the car this morning,
"I Don't Know My Name",
and I'm blown away by you.
- Thank you.
- She's so talented.
- Thank you, I'm blown away by you.
- You are mesmerizing, really incredible.
- I love that you're crying it's so cool.
- I'm not crying, I'm fine.
It was the initial shock.
- You shouldn't lose that though.
I think it's cool when you get so
excited about meeting people.
I'm 37 years old, and I
still, ask Meryl Streep,
I look like an idiot.
Like, but whatever I
don't care, I like her.
- Mine was Harrison Ford,
imagine how that went.
- Oh my god, was he quiet?
- I literally was like, I love you,
and he's like alright.
- So why Bear Claw?
Why was that your poll?
- I love New Girl.
I actually just did an interview with
Zooey Deschanel.
- Oh I love Zooey.
- Because I'm like a
die-hard New Girl fan.
But they told me on the
phone, they're like,
Okay so someone's gonna be
sitting with you on the couch,
and I'm like oh okay.
And I was like oh who is
it, and they were like
Josh Gad, and I was like who's that.
So I didn't know who that
was, but I'm like a huge fan.
But I know you as Bearclaw.
(laughter)
- There are so many emotions that
I'm going through right now.
(laughter)
Do you know who you were, then
when I learned who you were,
I cried.
- I cried really hard on the phone.
- I know what you mean though,
because I don't ever know
everybody's real names sometimes.
- Especially actors, I don't know actors.
- Yeah and I always think that they're
the person they were in
the movie and they're not.